with a talk by Laura Summers uh she is
originally from the US and she lived in
Australia and now she lives in Berlin
she works for explosion Ai and she has a
really interestingly titled talk for
us thank you so much thanks for that
intro so the talk title in case you
can't see it is okay
Doomer okay and my talk is
done um hi I'm Laura Summers it's so
nice to be here um I just wanted to
start by saying thank you so much to all
the organizers for all of the enormous
amount of hard work you do let's give
them a cla a like it's been such a great
conference and also this is only the
second like in real life event I've been
at in since Co and it's just such a
pleasure to see faces in the world so
I'm I'm really enjoying just like
talking to people and running into
people and finding incredibly weird
coincidences like we sat down next to
someone and they followed my husband
Andy on Twitter and they were like are
you Andy kitchen it's
like incredible so let's get into it so
I've been told I shouldn't run over hi
I'm Laura Summers I'm going to hit 20
years working in twch next year in 2024
so I have been around a little while um
I'm now working for explosion um and I'm
working as a design engineer and as the
product lead for this new prodct we're
working on prod teams we're very excited
about it please come chat to us about it
um most of my time in the industry has
been as a product designer so I've been
working in this design engineering
hybrid type of role um I'm a weirdo I
just like wearing a lot of hats I'm not
saying this is a thing people should
want to do it's just how my career has
ended up for reasons um and for the last
10 years or so I've been working mostly
in startups so small to mid-stage
startups so that's me I'd like to hang
around with tech people who've been
around for even longer than me so this
is a group of women I love and we have a
chat that's been going on for a while
called the unboss and it's about as
spicy as you can
imagine and you know these these folks
have been around in teex since Cobalt
and since you know seatan and all the
rest of it and they've seen some
proverbial go down so an ongoing
theme I have of chats with folks like
this is how boringly expected and un
imaginative text failure modes are these
days so here we have the um the sweat
shop on the left and the click Farm on
the right and yes I'm saying the one is
the modern analog of the other um you
know it's bad ideas new platform and
apologies to anyone working at
Clara um or it's the same in
shiny new Millennial
rebranding now I don't mean everything
of of course but I do mean all the ways
that technology is used to harm
control disempower and disenfranchise
people and I'll just quickly note that
I'm going to share a link to all my
slides later so if you want to read any
of the things I do have a ton of links
in here so don't feel like obliged to
find the URLs now I'll share a mega URL
at the
end um so around 2019 I read a book guys
steuart Russell called human compatible
and I thought it was you know
interesting but a little bit esot IC
like maybe a little bit stuffy
um and you know my impression was that
it was a fringe concern this idea of
like super intelligence like the
singularity I was like well cool but you
know is that really a Now
problem um a few years later I noticed
the Doomer movement starting to gain
steam so this is like 2020 2021 um so
Nick Bostrom wrote this book super
intelligence 2014 it really didn't take
off until this time time similarly he
founded this institute at Oxford which
is called the future of humanity
Institute um back in 2005 but again like
it only just started getting visible
right around
then similarly this guy elizer owski who
you might have seen on The Lex Freedman
videos um he in he founded this
institute called The Singularity
Institute which is kind of as culty as
it sounds um and then it was named The
Machine intelligence Research Institute
and that was back in 2000 but then just
around 2020 2021 it started really like
popping off you know people started
paying attention to them and if you've
been unaware of this movement I'll try
to charitably summarize their main
concerns so the first one is that we
could unintentionally build or luck into
sensient machine learning models with
intelligence that's on par or greater
than human
intelligence and the second is that
these models would then naturally want
to exterminate us at the worst or
enslave or oppress us at the best and I
will say not all doomers claim that the
second is inevitable but just that
there's a chance that it will happen and
it's a big enough chance that we need to
prepare for it
[Music]
man
so in 2022 and 2023 so few years later
there's been this explosion of press and
attention on the
movement um just nonstop dumer stuff
happening and I'll note
especially yosua Beno um who's one of
the three Godfathers of deep learning
jumping on the bandwagon fairly recently
and also Jeffrey Hinton the second of
the three Godfathers of deep learning
jump jumping on the bandwagon and you
know i' I've been asking myself well
this has been going since 2000 so what's
changed
why now and you know it has to be this
explosion in generative models and large
language models right like that's the
only thing that makes sense um this step
change in the capabilities of AI systems
has really had a ripple effect on our
Collective Consciousness but I really
want to ask the question do these new
models actually point a path to the idea
of human type intelligence or super
intelligence so here's Yan Lon who's the
third Godfather of deep learning
saying he holds the opposite position
and I will say like I don't agree with
him on lots of things but I'm shockingly
right on side with him in this
particular issue so he says that Jeffrey
believes that llms are smarter than I
believe they are and he's a little more
optimistic than I am about how they
might get us to human level
AI now my take if you haven't guessed
already is that no these things are not
scratching at Consciousness or human
level intelligence even if they are much
more General my guess is that even the
smartest amongst us even those who
should really know better are really
unable to keep a principled view of
large language models as soon as the
interaction feels too real we start
assigning them agency or in other words
as you can see here we can't stop
anthropomorphizing the machine as a
little side note if you haven't seen
Kismet it's this MIT media lab project
it's a babbling robot that does
turn-taking and people will sit and talk
to it for hours having nonsense
conversations and they think it's a
character they think it's a person and I
think this is a great example of like
the way that we can't stop assigning
agency to the machine even if there's
nothing remotely like that going
on so yeah I know I really do I know
there are deep debates about how
intelligent GPT really is and questions
about whether sufficiently being able to
approximate the shape of meaning is so
close as to be indistinguishable from
meaning
itself but I can't help feel that
focusing too much on that question of a
potential future evil angry intelligence
is just an a distraction like I love
this uring quote worrying about AI evil
superintelligent is worrying about
overpopulation on Mars when we haven't
even landed on the planet and apologies
Elon but that ain't happening
anytime
soon so yeah I mean I think we're really
missing the point and when this whole
top topic started in the world I saw
this meme on Twitter and I thought
that's beautiful it really captures my
feeling about the discussion it's like
you're just absolutely focusing on the
wrong thing but I'm going to extend it
okay so it's not a trolley it's not an
Ethics problem it's not an abstraction
it's a product and that product is
spitting cash out as it goes rolling
over the bodies of the people on the
tracks
and to extend the metaphor even one more
point I would say often the guy who used
to be at the switch is now sitting in a
bookstore somewhere signing his book
saying hey guys this one time I worried
my product might be super intelligent
someday and that same guy is saying
maybe we should stop you know designing
trolley now I was like okay cool story
bro um I've been having a debate with my
boss and colleague and friend Matt about
this and he thinks that we should be
able to work on X risk or Extinction
risk in a principled way alongside all
of the other things we care about all of
the other problems we want to solve in
the world and like I'm genuinely
sympathetic to this point of view and I
I want to say like I'm not here to like
you know do Team Edward versus Team
Jacob here like I'm here to like try and
spin up some
conversations um but like in my view
it's it's my sense my intuition that the
doomers are actively oppos opposed to
these disciplines that we kind of broad
Church call AI ethics or AI fairness
like they don't they they noticeably
don't engage with the scholarship go to
the conferences talk to the researchers
who are doing that work and there's tons
of them and I'm not even going to try
and name them all because they're
wonderful women and wonderful people of
color and yeah but there's tons of them
and I have heaps of resources in my
GitHub if you ever want to like go check
out like how to do AI auditing or data
data sheets for data sets or model cards
for models like all of those really
practical useful tools that they're
exploring um you know the other thing is
beyond this thing which is letterwriting
campaigns and saying hey we should stop
research I've really struggled to work
out what their actual concrete proposal
is like there doesn't seem to be that
much actual technique work offering
happening from the movement so to me
this is what it feels like the doomers
are bored by Boring ethics and they want
to just like go think about the cool new
AI
apocalypse and honestly I kind of get it
right it's easier to talk about the
singularity compared to the slow uneven
collapse of environment and Civil
Society that's already happening this is
like good disra good distraction good
procrastination and I think the mess of
Tangled systems and wicked problems is
what we really need to talk
about um oh I should hurry up a little
um
rather than the robot Rapture the single
point of failure oh oh sorry I'll say
something quickly about this quote I
love this this framing of the problem
because the engineer is calling this xrx
thing Extinction right um he's saying
like they're calling it Extinction it
sucks the air out of the room it means
there's no room for other discussion
it's sort of like eating the oxygen
right um so yeah I think the robot
Rapture the single point of failure the
one bomb to kill the whole world um yes
that's an Oppenheimer reference this is
the thing that's like fun to think about
but should really fundamentally just be
left to the science fiction writers and
we should get down in the weeds with the
interesting
problems um and I just want to say to
the side dor is really really love a
metaphysical scenario like I kept seeing
images of Dante's Hell and you know like
other hellscape type references and I'm
really struggling to take them seriously
as scientist when it feels much more
like religion or cult so I'm going to
leave that there so without going into
the weeds I'm just going to point you at
a couple resources I really like if
you're interested about this question of
AGI what it might actually look like
what engineering principles are missing
what we need to build what we need to
conceive of um I really like this second
one deep learning in AGI still a long
way to go and there's a podcast version
of this if you listen to the um data
cynic podcast or data sorry data skeptic
podcast which kind of embodies what I
like about data science so it's it's a
great it's a great podcast
um yeah so I I would highly recommend
having a deep read and I won't try and
like go into like the long form rebuttal
of the movement because that's you know
a 2hour talk not a 30 minute talk um but
yeah look I'm going to say this let's
just assume that we Grant all the dummer
premises let's say okay everything is
true buddy exactly I agree with you it's
coming for us the robots are going to
murder us they're going to like kick us
out of our homes whatever how do we prep
for the AI apocalypse well my pitch is
it's exactly the same stuff we should be
doing even if it didn't happen so I
think we missing all of this engineering
fundamentals Basics that we just really
should be including already and we're
not so this is software engineering
fundamentals that we should just bake
into our road maps to help make our
software more robust our models more
interpretable and our systems more
resilient
the second half of this talk is a
checklist of practical cheap and easy
things you can do to improve your models
and production or your Automation in its
context you do have to use your common
sense to identify which of these
proposals is cheap and easy for you
given your stack given your Frameworks
given your tooling so I'm going to say
you know like I can't assume that every
single one of these will be cheap and
easy given what's going on with your
system but I'm sure you can find at
least a few that are cheap or easy and
probably a couple more that might be
quite approachable and reachable without
too much effort with a little bit of
careful
engineering my particular interest is
the steam between your technology and
the outside
world the interface between machines and
humans not just UI but all touch points
and not just customers but all people
all humans impacted by the system if you
think that implementing these features
is not a h job I'm really want to
disagree with you it's my view that data
science and machine learning expertise
is really really important really
imperative to the correct implementation
of all of these features and importantly
it's it's so crucial for the correct
interpretation of the signal that the
features produce so please don't think
oh right I can tune out for the second
half of this this is not a me job I
really think everyone in here has
something very important to offer to the
like implementation and doing work of
all of the these kinds of
tools so the first one I'd like to offer
is a
baseline I'm hoping this isn't really
that surprising a story or surprising a
concept but just quickly to say this
Baseline as in like a simpler version of
a Model A simpler version of your
automation your algorithm your tool so
like having having a conceptual smaller
map to go next to your bigger map so
that you have something to compare it
to um I really love this story my lovely
husband Andy told me this um he went to
this hackathon a data science hackathon
with a friend and they were all trying
to write an algorithm to predict the
weather so they were trying to come up
with a weather predictor that could you
know highly accurately predict
tomorrow's weather and a whole bunch of
teams went away and they did all these
cool features and you know feature
engineering and they did all of this
like you know crazy work and someone
went and did like a multimodal like
approach and people did very cool very
big things but the one that won was this
it's an average it is literally an
average and the average is today's
temperature plus the temperature from
tomorrow's datee last year divided by
two and it went on accuracy
interpretability ease of implementation
like everything you can imagine and it's
also just like elegant right and I think
that we often forget that things like
this exist in the world and that we can
like look for them and that we don't
have to go to the like most
uninterpretable model like as the first
step
so when I say Baseline I really mean in
a broad sense so this could be as I as
we saw simple calculation or just basic
Computer Logic you could have some
business rules that need to be encoded I
mean I'm sorry to say this but maybe
there's something interesting in that
macro that you're like colleague wrote
20 years ago in an Excel spreadsheet
right that's there's often gold in there
there's like interesting opinions and
ideas about the problem space like
encoded in logic and just because it's
not python doesn't mean we get to poo
poo
it
you could also think of just a simpler
model right so it could be a linear
regression um and if you're using an API
and I know lots of folks are building on
top of like you know the open AI like
paid apis now you can use a different
version of the model or look for an open
source alternative or try just another
paid API but basically just try the same
thing somewhere else right just make
sure you have something to compare it to
so the one precious baby brought into
the world doesn't have a sibling to
compare it to right like you want to
know if it's actually thriving and doing
well the second Pitch I'd like to offer
is this idea of a kill
switch now I I have to make more jokes
and I do have to say like I'm pretty
sure the designers of the Terminator
were pretty mad at themselves that they
didn't bacon and Kel switch because that
would have gotten rid of that whole epic
Saga of
stories but even seriously there's this
very interesting and honestly I find
kind of entertaining um devops
cautionary Tale called nightmare a
devops cautionary tale and it's it's
essentially uh night Capital was a like
algorithmic trading platform and they
managed to like miraculously wipe $400
million in Assets in 45 minutes and I I
find that like honestly an impressive
feat like I don't know how the hell you
managed to do that it's kind of again
mindblowing but the thing look I I
highly recommend reading the article if
you're interested in me like like if
you're interested did like me and things
like you know Tangled systems and like
how things fall down and where where
like you know the checks and balances
didn't work but um even if you're not
interested in that just like the top
level story is if they had had a kill
switch implemented they could have
pressed it on minute one and saved all
of that money so like you know honestly
kill switches save I won't say lives but
they they certainly save
assets that's
awkward but yeah can that look like I
mean it can be as simple as having a
maintenance Road right like you you
don't have to keep everything live if
you if you just have a maintenance mode
page that you can switch over to with
your app in production so if the model
goes off the rails if you see it
drifting if you see some weird
predictions coming out of it you just
have something that you can turn on so
that people know that your app or your
website is still live quite simple now
if you had that Baseline that we talked
about in the first point you could also
imagine being able to roll back to it so
this is a nice way of thinking well hey
we had the cool model running but
actually we don't want to take our whole
system offline so if we can have like
some if logic that reverts to that then
we have a way of building more
resilience more robustness into the
system um you can also Imagine doing
system roll back but I will say this is
hard mode because it's been my
experience and I don't want to be snarky
and if this is not true of you don't see
it as a as an attack but it has been my
experience that most folks don't have
Version Control running on their model
or their training data let alone their
model and their training data and I
think you need both if what you want is
to be able to do system roll back
because you have to know the state of
your model and the state of the data to
know that's a safe place in time to go
back to but if you are doing that and
you're doing release management or some
combination of those two things and you
feel confident you know the state of
your system going backwards in time you
can do this thing the system roll back
and you can just push it to a previously
working State while you go and
feverishly work out what the problem is
and then you can push your patch and
everything is
good the third thing I want to talk
about is exposing the machine and by
this I mean popping the hood like
drawing back the curtain letting folks
see what's going
on um the simplest thing to do here is
just label it say hi I'm a robot not a
person job is done takes two minutes I I
think most folks have a hard time in
sort of imagining how this works in
their system because it feels like
you're taking away the marketing magic
but honestly people already think that
things are robots even when they're
people it's just better to say it um the
next thing you can do is Imagine things
like exposing machine confidence like
you might need to do some thinking about
what accuracy scores you're using is it
Precision or recall are you using F1
score like what tools you're using to
try and assess the quality of your model
but once you work that out you can
certainly come up with a human
interpretable way to expose that to
people on the other side of the system
um and here you can see we've got a
little puppy that's been miscalculated
as a as a kitten um and we've got the
added bonus of letting the user tell the
system that doesn't seem right um and
that's a another thing I think we should
be doing and I get to that in feedback
loops another thing you can do here is
phone a human friend so you might say
like 99% of the time our confidence
levels are high enough and we feel like
we can give a pretty good answer but
that last 1% of the time maybe we just
shouldn't attempt to maybe we just think
our confidence is not high enough and
not going to provide a good quality
prediction classification Etc so instead
of attempting to do that and giving a
bad result into the world we can just
say hey we're not sure we need to have
human review this this particular like
record or depending on your system you
could imagine offering two options to
the world and saying we think it might
be a or b but we're not sure what do you
think it is and again that turns into
training data and you help make your
model better in real
time you also so if possible really want
to try and explain your machine
decisions so by this I mean anything you
know about the features that go into the
decision outcome anything that helps
users understand why they're getting
what they're getting and if they agree
to
it the fifth thing I want to talk about
is having a paper trail so this is
basically just knowing what happened
when it happened and what the state of
the world was when it happened so to
make that real we want a decision Rec
which knows what system version we were
on we were talking before about doing
like system um release management and
having like some some you know like
control some Version Control happening
on both like the code of our model and
the state of our data sets um this is
this is the thing that we needed for so
that we can like detect back in time
what was happening and like work out why
that decision happened if it was
wrong um you also want to make sure you
have a decision ID or a transaction ID
for that record plus that state of the
world and that moment in time right like
most folks go through a machine machine
learning like decision process get to
the end and then suddenly that moment is
lost in time and they have no record to
be like oh well this happened to me and
here is my like receipt here's the thing
go investigate it for me um so yeah
think about what does that uuid look
like where do you put it how do you
store it um how is it used to be
reinterpreting the system if someone
needs to take a look at
um you can also think about improving
your logs your audit Trail and again
this is like very boring eat your
vegetable stuff but logging really
matters um again that's a whole talk but
please please make sure that your logs
are interpretable that you can look at
them and understand what they're trying
to tell
you um I also just want to wave quickly
at this idea of decision recourse this
is a thing that is again its own topic
um it's being able to interrogate a
system as a user and say I don't think
that's right can you please do it it
again give me you know can someone
review my decision can someone tell me
if it's correct um I don't think I can
remotely try to cover it right now but I
will just say that if these things are
not in place you don't have a hope of
doing this thing so just make sure that
you get the fundamentals in place to be
able to keep
going and the last thing I want to talk
about is oh no I have two more things oh
no no this is last thing limiting blast
radius so this is doing your model in
production with fewer people to start
with that's the point start with fewer
people and move on from there so this
means having a trial run a beta phase
and making sure that you work out who's
the right early adopter selecting that
group communicating with them
intensively and assuming that your
system will fail when you're ready to do
your first production run again you can
do it as a phase roll out you don't have
to turn on the floodgates for everybody
you can pick a 100 people at a time it's
much easier to have a failure mode at a
100 than is at a th000 or 10,000
Etc again same exact
points you can also use feature Flags so
once your model is in production you can
say well hey I want to hide this for 90%
of my users but try it out on a few
folks first and see what
happens and the last thing I really am
nearly finished I'm sorry is feedback
loops we want to consider all the users
of our system just going to get to the
end of this so we can sorry so this is
customers people who pay for it this is
operators people who like administer
developers anybody who's using the
system to try and get it to Output what
it outputs this is also people who do
the training data this is labelers this
is annotators um this is the people who
the system makes decisions or
predictions about and it's end users so
it's people who use native or web
apps I suggest that you frontload your
feedback efforts because it's easier to
talk to 10 people than a 100 or a
thousand and I also suggest I'm just
going to go to the end again that you
really try to talk to them directly
especially early on create a slack
through them into it have a shared
Discord whatever you like but just let
people reach out to you in real time and
then as the system matures start picking
those feedback loops into the UI into
the inter interface but you don't have
to do that at first you just need like a
couple of folks who know that you're
there to listen and your job is
done okay all right I'm going to
just go past this because I'm at time
and this there is a cheat sheet which
will be in my links so if you want to be
reminded of all of these big points that
we talked about please go get it and if
you get this this is a QR code I created
with hugging face um like a Transformer
to do like cool QR Code
art if you scan this you get the slides
which follow which is all the links so
yeah I'll leave that up thank you so
much for your attention sorry for
running short really appreciate
it